amd has truly changed the game while out
playing intel in nearly every way
they're still making brand new gpus for
gamers around the world to enjoy it's a
tough job to battle two giants at once
but they can't let nvidia take all the
glory and graphics and tomorrow amd
makes their next move
yes
on march 18th amd releases the rx 6700xt
a gpu literally no one is asking for in
the middle of a massive shortage of
existing graphics cards we'd be happy to
buy
but that doesn't mean it has to be bad
no
many people will buy these but the
question is
will you be happy to have one
like i'm happy to tell you about our
sponsor redux
redux is a pc builder striving to bring
pc gaming to the masses by offering the
same prices that if you built it
yourself plus a 75 build fee check the
link in the description below and start
creating your pc today
[Music]
paper launch jokes aside we've already
discussed what availability is going to
be like for this gpu
basically if you don't have a
well-maintained f5 key or a bot
you're probably not going to be able to
buy one on launch day as with nvidia and
the rtx 3060 i don't know why amd has
decided now is the best time to release
a new gpu but this is a review of the
card itself so let's start with that
the
reference rx 6700xt
that is what it is right reference it
looks pretty sharp it's not identical to
the rest of the big navi lineup but it's
got enough of the styling to let you
know they're related there's much less
weight to the cooler than even the 2
slot rx 6800 which is curious given that
card is rated for just 20 watts more
power it also has 4 fewer gigs of gddr6
memory which amd confirmed is running at
the same speed but is now constrained to
a 192-bit bus instead of a 256-bit one
meaning the diminished 96 megabytes of
infinity cache will need to somehow pick
up a lot more slack but the rx 6700xt is
in a completely different price bracket
than the rx 6800 so maybe these changes
won't be such a big deal in practice so
let's meet the cards we think will make
a better comparison we've got the nvidia
geforce rtx 3070 the 3060 ti the 2080
super and amd's own last gen rx 5700 xt
and they'll all go into our gpu bench
for a fair fight shadow the tomb raider
has the 6700 xt right in between the rtx
3070 and 3060 ti which isn't a strong
start when we turn on ray tracing even
the rtx 2080 super out does it we did
predict this in our announcement
analysis but it's still a shock to the
system given how much worse it performs
than even the rtx 3060 ti
which i should remind you as a card that
allegedly retails for 80 less apparently
there's relatively simple optimizations
that can significantly improve amd's
performance in ray tracing though so
stay tuned for that in future titles and
patches for now let's go back to our
tests it's not just tomb raider that's
kind of disappointing
the rmx 6700 xt is only as good as the
rtx 3060 ti in f1 2020 wolfenstein
youngblood and flight sim 2020 i mean
thankfully forza horizon 4 provides some
relief for amd placing the 6700 xt at
the very top of the pack for once it's
not a great showing unfortunately
it is worth noting though that hardware
unboxed recently did a video on running
modern gpus with weaker hardware and
found that lower end cpus like the ryzen
5 from 1st gen to 3rd gen actually
perform better with radeon gpus than
nvidia's do so perhaps that's another
angle to consider when looking at these
results this class of gpu isn't really
for productivity and amd says gaming is
already an a2's top priority but the
workstation arena
is definitely not radion stronghold
anymore the rx 6700xt xt is getting
slaughtered in blender and this is
before we even consider the ray
accelerated optics renderer puget bench
doesn't do amd any favors either even
though the cpu does most of the heavy
lifting here it's placing well below
even the rtx 2080 super through most of
these tests although it does come a
little closer to the cheaper 3060 ti and
indigo renderer
lux mark
is a bloodbath i'm not sure what's going
on here to make amd fall so far behind
but if you do any productivity on the
side you
probably don't want to reach for team
red
well at least you can always reach for a
water bottle with ltc store.com
there it is
maybe power consumption is a lot lower
that wouldn't excuse this kind of cost
to performance imbalance but it would
give amd a niche to occupy at least
except it isn't a lot lower peak
recorded power draw is higher than the
rtx 3060 ti although on average it is
nearly 10 watts less decent but
definitely not a niche maker
thermals well they're well controlled
but not as good as nvidia's founder's
edition aside from when nvidia just kind
of takes a nap and the more memory
hungry tests that is
clock stability looks a little more
varied than nvidia though it is well
above the advertised 2.4 gigahertz game
clock so
in the end the radeon 6700 xt didn't
really stand out at all by our numbers
anyway most frustratingly amd's official
marketing positions it as a competitor
to the similarly priced rtx 3070 but if
you average it all out it's a good seven
percent off of that card while only
being about three percent better than
the rtx 3060 ti this thing should really
be priced closer to 429 and positioned
as an answer to the 3060 ti
not against the 30-70 as it stands the
pricing is completely out of whack and
if i were more cynical i'd say that they
priced it this way because they know
gamers will pay for it under current
market conditions
but i'm not going to say that with a
straight face i want to give amd the
benefit of the doubt here from what amd
tells us our numbers are roughly in line
with their internal testing so when we
compare amd's published performance
numbers we can see that in some cases at
least it should perform closer to what
its price point suggests it just may
well be that the true value of the rx
6700 xt will be wildly different
depending on what games you play and at
what settings it just so happens that
the test suite we've been using for the
past several gpu launches hasn't been
particularly kind to it and maybe that's
the real conclusion here for those of
you who have been waiting for the
opportunity to buy
a new gpu any new gpu
well
you could do worse for those of you
waiting for pricing to settle first it
seems like the rtx 3060 ti
is simply the more well-rounded card but
if the stars align and the games you
care about run well in radeon and
especially if you're running older
hardware
then
it could be a great deal after all
just like our sponsor ting thanks to
ting mobile for sponsoring today's video
their new rates make it easier to see
how much you can save by switching
you've got unlimited talk and text plans
for ten dollars data plans start at
fifteen dollars and unlimited data for
forty five if you liked their previous
pay what you use plans they're still
there they're just called ting flux
plans now and they charge just five
dollars per gig data can also be shared
if you have a family plan and you can
connect more phones to save more and
you'll still get award-winning
nationwide coverage pretty much any
phone will work with ting mobile so
check them out at linus.ting.com and
receive a 25 credit thanks for watching
guys if you're looking for more
unobtainium to watch go check out our
review of the rtx 3060 a lower end gpu
that goes for double this card's price
on ebay and whose money limiter was
recently bypassed as we all knew it
would be because miners yay
unhackable